welcome to the podcast guys it's going
do well are you good good alright Ryan
so for those of our listeners who don't
know who you are
what do you work on so start a company
five years ago almost or actually just
over five years ago called producthunt
place to discover new products you see a
lot of makers and companies launching
their new apps or their new products of
the world and kind of like reddit or
hacker news yet people commenting asking
questions and uploading what they think
is most cool mm-hmm insulting
I'm Dalton I'm a partner at Y Combinator
I'm also the head of Admissions so
that's the selection process for who we
fund and I actually worked at YC when
product hunt was NYC and so I remember
it from the inside kind of what the
story was were you there for the
interview I was not deny here you know
do you remember who it was yeah it was
Sam who else was it it was such a blur
it was ten minutes of just rapid-fire
questions and I was like right anyway I
can't remember who else it was yeah
anyway all right cool yeah so Dalton I
think he has a question for you to start
it off yeah so maybe to start with like
because I remember it so well from being
there
walk me through from the formation a
product hunt into applying to I see into
getting into that interview that is
already a blur was I there I don't even
up it that's a very common thing by the
way it's almost like an out-of-body
experience you people don't remember
them that well so it's not just you this
is can hear that I hear that a lot work
there's a lot of anxiety when you go
into it frankly and you know you try to
well someone gave me this advice
actually during YC is before you do
anything like that before you do a pitch
pump your chest physically it might have
been Kevin Hale that service yeah I
could be wrong so sorry Kevin if I'm
putting words in your mouth but there
there's a step where you can like pump
your chest physically and that act of
physical nature of like doing something
that feels like a little bit aggressive
can inspire some confidence and a you
know it's actually I may have done that
a few different times you know
throughout my career I'm not gonna lie
I've never heard that device before but
yeah that was okay Travis and Jordan
Pearson's first rule in his book it says
stand up straight with your shoulders
back
anyway all right okay so you blacked out
during the interview but yeah what else
was a process like yeah so see where can
I start so product on I'll do the
beginning really really quickly is
started off as a side project and it was
right between startups I was leaving in
another one and kind of tinkering and
interviewing at other startups started
product on it started off as an email
list got some traction there that then
turned into a website and we looked a
lot a lot of inspiration like Reddit and
hacker news and other communities and
like how do you what systems do want to
take inspiration from how do we want
people to engage and so we built that
that got some traction and it's probably
for I want to say four months after the
email started and when the website was
kind of operating there's still a side
project it was not incorporated it was
still like a thing I woke up every
morning super excited about and found my
mind continually 24/7 focusing on it but
I still didn't know what we wanted to
turn it into and then it was around the
four month time period I just got a DM
from Nicholas from algo Lea yeah they
were in the previous YC batch and I
interviewed them oh well he DM me and
said hey hey Ryan you know a lot of
people at YC are using product hunt
they're launching their products there
Gary tan would love to meet you have you
thought about joining YC and it was the
perfect time because I was sort of at
that crossroads where I'm like what do
we do with this you know we could keep
doing it as a side project we could make
it a company if you make it a company
how do you how do you build do you raise
money do you not so a lot of a lot of
questions so I initially said oh I'd
love to meet Gary we went to the Grove
on I think mission Street and my
questions were Gary were pretty
transparent I was like hey Gary this is
working here the numbers I love doing
this
but I'm not sure I want to take VC
funding and I mean if I go into YC if we
do YC does that mean we're on that path
and uh Gary Gary said something along
the lines of like well when you strike
lightning in a bottle it doesn't happen
very often and I'm and I say that not
arrogantly it's not that like product
it's the most amazing best thing in the
world it's not but very few times in
your life to you build something that is
like wow
there's something there that is true and
that advice stuck with me and Gary was
not ever you never pressured me to say
you should do YC or you should raise EC
funding but that that advice or that
feedback was really insightful because
he's right Slyke is am I ever gonna have
a time in my life where I build
something that is starting to show some
sort of traction that's something that
people want ultimately do you remember
what the growth rate was when you
applied to IC yeah we if I'm not
mistaken I think we were like 50 percent
month-over-month and that's not counting
like with hundred users and month one
but it was like over the course of a few
months with some some users and so it
was and actually going into the
interview I'm fast-forwarding a little
bit but we found out some things that
worked on the growth side and a lot of
it was a very manual me basically
emailing makers and founders and
tweeting at them and I found out that
when I messaged them they would join the
conversation they would share and that
would drive more traffic to the site and
so there's a nice flywheel effect that
still exists today and when I discovered
when we discovered that I was like well
shoot let me should do that more often
and let me do that as is fast and as
quickly as I can going into the
interview so that I can say honestly in
the interview yeah we have 50 percent
month-over-month growth and past like
three months and uh and so anyway that
was having those types of metrics gave
me a lot more confidence you know I
didn't have to put much error maybe I
should have but I didn't have to pump my
chest to feel confident going into the
interview even though it was kind of
anxiety inducing because it's such a
quick process yeah I've had similar
conversations with folks like the one
Gary hi with you and sometimes what I do
is actually discourage someone from
doing immature of financing if they have
a side project working especially if
they're making money and they never will
have like they can support themselves on
it and it basically have the job forever
and you have this like cool freedom that
so many people dream of yeah I'm
sometimes like hey like keep doing that
okay like you you're living the dream
the grass is not greener on the other
side and if you do want to decide to
raise money just make sure you're doing
it for the right reasons that you're
really excited about it not that someone
told you to or you're seeking approval
from for
authority figures you know trying to say
like right you wanted to come and so
what it sounds like what was good in
your case is you were like very on board
versus again sometimes you see people
you push down this path where they have
something working and then they they
regret it in the future
yeah because the one-way door wave good
job right or a good lifestyle yeah I
mean it's this weird thing right where
you think like startup equals software
right so like because I'm making
profitable software therefore it is a
startup but it can equally be a small
business yeah and more likely
semantically you can call it a start-up
to I just maybe it's like the VC
yeah line in the sand it's not for
everybody and especially like I really
respect there's so many great indie
software developers building like Mac
software and like they make a good
living and like yeah they got it I think
they have a lot figured out that other
people don't
yeah and so those people I'm like yeah I
don't know if this is I think you keep
doing what you're doing yeah that's
that's the the thought process that went
through my head and so there was a
scenario and I was trying to imagine
well let's see if first off I didn't
have much in savings and I'm not an
engineer and so that was one of the
things as well I need people to help me
to build this thing and build out know
this roadmap that I have in my brain and
and so one way of to do that is you get
money to pay them well how to get money
you could do it through VC or you can
you know make money in the product
itself you know there's other other
means to get money but I was certainly
evaluating well what if we never raised
VC money what if I could pocket twenty
thousand dollars in my pocket per month
over some of the business that'd be
amazing and it's not what wirecutter did
do you know do you know the wire cutter
folks yes it didn't they don't strap it
off the affiliate links and yeah never
raised is that right yeah it's possible
I don't know if Brian and team raised
maybe they were it did friends a family
like a certain but they never raised
like a real VC full round yeah and
that's 30 million yeah yeah yeah yeah I
did well there you go
yeah and and even look at what Gabe's
down the Technium which they're on
forever yeah you know it's it's been
it's it's briefly a force in like a
thing that everyone in technology knows
about uses every day yeah and it doesn't
he hasn't raised money and if he did
raise money the product would change
dramatically they'd have to figure out
they have figured a lot of things to
change it for conferences that would be
my guess
I've actually talked to him about this
so yeah I don't think that'll be his
first choice but yeah I don't think he
doesn't seem like the conference kind of
guy does not you know this is a little
bit of a tangent but what did you think
of when indie hackers started to come up
because that was a little bit after
product hunt and is very similar and
it's within this exact niche
yeah yeah I've been thinking more and
more about in my head I describe it as
like maker communities and I would put
you know pro tent in that category indie
hackers L path is certainly one of those
and a bunch of others and these are sort
of communities that are designed and
some of them are verticalized around a
specific function or whether it's like
dribble for designers Stack Overflow for
engineers and/or its demographic base
like L path for women and there's like
this whole ecosystem maker communities
in the internet and I find it really
fascinating because it's it's largely
built into the thesis of product n which
was always well I love discovering
products there's like this cultural
relevance and interest within products
and technology and more more people of
building products in fact next five
years are gonna seem a ridiculous number
of products being built partly because
it's more accessible it's easier you
don't actually need any money to build
anything anyone with the motivation and
an internet access can like build
something so I'm going off on a tangent
little bit now but I seem indie hackers
is certainly filling this sort of niche
in this focus around like bootstrapped
entrepreneurs and that's like their
focus within this kind of maker
community ecosystem for me and what
courtland's done is is great I've you
know I participate in community I've
been on this podcast I'm seeing tonight
actually just funny okay I love what
they're doing okay but but not all
companies that go through YC ultimately
raise money afterward right leg zapier
is a good example is rich yeah right and
so and they predated producthunt
right so I think kind of what dalton was
alluding to like so you had this like
point where you could have raised money
or could have not raised money mm-hm and
so demo day like why do you decide to
follow that path yeah so the the story
with with us going through YC so we we
raised
around around the same time we got into
YC and part of the strategy was one
we're building something for the tech
community and strategically it was
important or rather beneficial for us to
get a lot of notable tech people
involved so we raised money from like GV
Greylock SV angel labor the first
check-in a bunch of other like Street
cheeks and and having them involved was
just helpful to have like the support
community and granted we probably gave
up more equity than we needed to we
raised a million before like going into
YC before demo day when we were
targeting like 400k but we got great
people around us and and then fast
forward through demo day Marc Andreessen
reached out kind of in the middle and
he'd been following it and was
interested and we met up and and that
happened then three or four weeks later
he contact again is and this was pre
demo day and it was sort of you know how
are things going and I knew what that
meant you know they were interested in
long story short they ended up doing a
series they preemptively we were pretty
early especially for injured snorts to
do that that nip around but the the
metrics are great the the vision or
rather the the opportunity massive and I
felt that it was it was better to you
know work with a great firm and raise
more capital now than risk in six months
raising with maybe not as good of a firm
with maybe not as strong in numbers and
that money that when then would allow us
to continue for several years you know
building the company and hiring and
building out would want to build and so
I think my perspective working to YC is
your experience was a hundred percent a
side effect of the lightning in a bottle
effect you had and is not at all
representative with ninety-eight percent
of the people in YC that is just not how
it happens and the reason is people
don't have buzz or excitement and
because you're a community they were
participating in the community and so
it's very hard in that era you know
everyone was using your site and so you
see these things sometimes when there's
social products that take off yeah
everyone has on them all the time I mean
I'm not gonna yeah I can think of where
there was like the big things that were
hot yeah and then everyone got excited
about them but like it's it's
fascinating hearing you say that cuz
like seriously that is no one's
experience like
he's like 1% of the batch has that
experience and the other thing that I
would say is like those aren't already
always correlated with the companies
that like do really well in the long
term yeah I'm trying to say it in a nice
way but like yeah when you see this and
it's usually because someone has like a
hit yeah on their hands and so all the
investors like circle around and do all
this extra work to do it but if you look
at like a great example I like to talk
about is coinbase like he couldn't raise
from anyone I think he got like half a
million bucks
yeah the 2013 winner summer twelfth
summer - oh wow absolutely there's
companies like when amazed were like
they couldn't get people to return their
phone calls yeah and like couldn't I
think couldn't put together that much
money and you know like has a long term
investment when you love to be an
investor in that I you know like I
wasn't like I think the price is pretty
good and so we so what we seen from our
side of the table and YC is like
excitement around the core product or
feeling like other investors are excited
about it and things like that definitely
give a founder like yourself tons of
leverage mm-hmm
but that I actually have learned to not
take that too seriously as an investor
as a signal for how the company will do
it's more of just like oh you know like
people like scooters or something you
know there's other examples of these
hype cycles happening yeah and to try to
like remember that it's the long term
things that really matter like retention
and growth and revenue and those are
those are super predictive at demo yeah
so yeah so anyway I just like I remember
that too when you were everyone was like
so excited to buy product hunt and
everyone to work with you and they put
tons of work into it
mm-hmm and like yeah other founders
probably we're like why can't I be that
like yeah I think I think part of the
challenge is is you know some of the
best investments are somewhat contrarian
so coin based being a great example in
2012
you know crypto and that whole world was
just like a totally different era yeah
and you know the best investments often
times give us a single founder at the
time right yeah it was a single founder
everything was he was it doing it yes I
didn't know as like Brian Armstrong like
just Brian yeah it was like cool like
yeah I'm the Bitcoin guy and I'm it's
just me so
he had a lot of it was not a slam-dunk
at demo day were for coinbase
and it takes some conviction for like
the future the people that didn't invest
saw a future of crypto and what it could
become
and so they placed a bet on him and
that's that's where I think maybe it
gets challenging is if it's already
superhot then there's probably also a
lot of other companies competing for
that same real estate and I think my
product is probably not the best example
because we're not it's not like a lyft
and uber situation likes not like we
have a zero-sum game when it comes to
competition with other other companies
but yeah I think that's that's true I've
seen you know there's some I'm trying to
think back on the batch and who's who
what were you summer 14 summary 14 yeah
yeah so I think ginko is extreme like
they probably have hundreds of employees
there they're they're a biotech company
again like I think they raise fine but
there was not this like hot buzz oak
ginkgo buyer works they're from Boston
they're yeah you know they're doing
synthetic biology like you like I don't
think my country Singh was cold emailing
them yeah yeah and so like who else was
in summer 14 but there were the nuclear
companies remember the octo and the
fusion and the fishing company we're in
summer 14 so there was like stuff like
that but it was it would be easy to
forget and this is also why what's
fascinating working here man is people
think that YC funds consumer companies
and this is what our bread and butter is
yeah and like yeah like I think it's
like 5% consumer yeah it's it's funny
people think that most of product n is
actually consumer as well yes it's
probably I don't know 50% at most is
consumer there's a lot of b2b stuff on
yeah well I mean they're just the
loudest oh that makes sense reddit like
drop our Airbnb but man if you actually
look at the data which is my job to do
a huge percentage is like good
old-fashioned b2b enterprise there's a
lot of hard tech these days and people
just don't think about them mm-hm and
it's not because they're not good
businesses there's they're less fun to
talk about then and they just don't
maybe like I don't understand biotech
yeah it's less exciting for me simply
for that reason because they just don't
understand it wait and you don't know
where the markets going right worried
like when you think about Airbnb you're
like oh I could see myself doing that
yeah and then you just start doing it so
I'm curious Dolan about
application surprises on your end
because I think like both of you guys
having done investments as well you can
understand like the market gets like
really frothy and yeah maybe I don't
want to do that deal and I have to be
principled or maybe you do do the deal
and that's how it goes
what were the companies that we're like
I don't know about this and then they
went on to be like quite successful well
there's a lot of famous cases of people
that we fund and then they end up
pivoting into something wildly different
and that ends up being pretty good so my
my example that I had a front-row seat
for was Breck's I funded them to do a VR
headset thing and I was I was a credit
card company yeah
well I didn't know that and they I was I
interviewed them I was the group partner
I was their main contact through the
whole thing and you know they they
didn't know a lot about VR headsets I
think and you know this sort of came out
during during the batch and during
office hours that you know perhaps they
might want to consider something they
knew more about and they had prior built
something sort of like strike for Brazil
when they were younger
hmm and so the idea was like hey maybe
you should work on some FinTech stuff
that you that you know more about and it
was like well what should the product be
I'm like well what can you sell all the
people in your batch like you should
talk to people where they want oh like
and so the credit card thing just kind
of came out organically hmm and that was
like six weeks before demo day Wow and
so there is there's no way you could
have known that the folks working on the
VR headset idea they didn't know much
about hardware we're gonna end up being
a pretty good company yeah so you were
just surprised you like them as
engineers right place right time and
look you know lots of people that are
super high caliber but that was one
where certainly there was not a lot of
hype about their VR headset idea yeah
and I and they could have just gone all
the way through it and I don't I think
it would have been a struggle do you
remember what that conversation was like
because I think this is a it's a super
common question we get for the podcast
yeah people who change their ideas
what were those conversations like with
them what was a progress looking like
did they even have a product they did
not I think they ran into some pretty
fundamental issues that they
didn't know how to fix and they didn't
know how to get around them they had
they hit a roadblock and I definitely
did encourage them to maybe in a very
nice way to maybe like why always
encourage people if they're thinking
about maybe pivoting to go more towards
something they're deep experts in that
they know more about nothing less about
right and so you knew all about
community like you were in the right
place for you and you still are right so
you you want to find a good like
cohesion of a founder doing something
that plays to their strengths sometimes
people pivot into stuff that they know
nothing about and I'm pretty sure that
is not correlated with success it's yeah
it's like if you try to pivot into
biotech yeah like oh like biotech see me
yeah yeah product on is is like product
has me in many ways better worse than
it's just what I love I love products
and it's what me my friends were doing
is so felt it was just fun and actually
I tend to when I talk to founders who
are people who want to start a company
sometimes people overthink it like I
need to start a business and I need to
think about markets and everything and
I'm just
I'd like change your frame of mind think
about it as an experiment or a side
project and when you put your frame of
mind of like a side project first you
start to you sort of settle most people
start to settle in well what would I
want to build or what would I what could
I use and it's just a lot better way to
start I think personally so do you think
there's a way to play it over again
where you could've should've would've
monetized or expanded faster because
again this is especially if we're
talking about non venture funded things
it's that like a choice if you're
bootstrapping
about whether or not you charge for your
product right and so just like where
would you advise yourself you know so
you have a time machine you could advise
your younger self what would you have
told yourself around monetization or
would have been like you know what
wouldn't change anything
like yeah that's a valid option it's
yeah it's one of those things cuz
there's a lot of mistakes I made of
course and so I when I think about the
mistakes I think well I should have done
differently and then there's another
part of me though that thinks well with
the information I had at the time I
probably still would have made the same
decision so the reality is I don't think
things would have changed and it's also
hard to know if I did that would that
have actually been worse than what
happened and totally fair so the things
that I I think we made a mistake on that
I take responsibility for our few
different things one of them
one of them is we should have dedicated
a little bit of time and focus on
revenue and in the beginning before we
were funded we were you know I was
paying the Heroku bill out of my own
credit card and it wasn't expensive but
like a couple thousand dollars a month
maybe at one point and I was like well I
don't want to pay this so let's like do
job ads yeah and so we did Java ad to me
like four thousand dollars a month so
not much but like there's clearly like
very easy money like with our community
it wouldn't have taken much work to make
a little bit of money to increase our
runway ultimately the challenge is
always especially with consumer kind of
focus startup is as soon as you start
making money then VCS will start judging
you based on that revenue today and so
strategically there's some challenges
there which is an unfortunate byproduct
and I think a lot of investors think
yeah for what it's worth I would always
tell someone like to make that money
like I wouldn't judge someone for having
small amounts of revenue yeah if this
was in someone's application they're
like yeah we're making this money from
job ads that would be like cool like
yeah makes it very smart like it's right
I would in no way cause me to me less
psyched about the company if I read that
in like an application or something yeah
I mean I'm trying to think of a scenario
where that would be hurting their
company like maybe if it was affecting
growth negatively somehow right like you
know I ant banner ads for jobs I feel
like in a lot of media companies what
people end up starting with is
affiliates and so it certainly that's
how wirecutter works is like if you
click on the thing you buy it on Amazon
they get an 3% and it is very hard to
build a huge huge huge company doing
that but it certainly helps when people
are doing communities or things around
discovery right that's a pretty
tried-and-true way to pay the bills yeah
yeah and yeah I think it's there's is a
difference between a good job board but
then if if VCS if investors perceive it
is well that's that's the the business
model and that's the mechanics of how
you're going to make money and if it's
not impressive then there'll be
potential less excited it's just weird
it's this weird game that you have to
play so one thing would be make money
extend runway and start proving out some
ideas early cuz taking making money
takes a while we we focused on that last
year and now we're profitable yeah and
so that was like our number one goal is
just you know let's
cover our cost and and that just took a
while took a lot of experimentation to
get there and a push on this again I'm
just picturing back in the batch you
kind of could have gone deeper on
products like really deep on just tech
products and done like mm-hmm I don't
know a partnership there's ways you
could go deep on that I remember there
was ideas to expand to discovering other
kinds of things and like you can
discover a name I don't remember the
current status that feature but games is
one of those how much diversification
about the kind of stuff you discover
that's one way to do it the other thing
you've done is use the traffic you have
and bootstrap
things like a job board or there's a
scenario where you literally could have
become angellist right like you could
have gone really deep on that and so I
can I can like it's your company but I
could pitch like five different
scenarios where you could have sort of
zeroed in on what you are most excited
about as a founder and by going deep on
those it would become more evident if
you know those are all wildly different
companies I just pitched but from that
lightning and bottle that you had mmm
you could have like gone deep on one of
those and it seems like your decision
was to stick with the core tech product
thing and you wanted to be really
thoughtful about your community and I
remember there's some redesigns I don't
know like walking through how you liked
when you had all these options on the
table strategically how you decided what
was exciting to you and always like yeah
we're not I don't want to do a job or
that sounds horrible it was a very good
you don't yeah I think I would agree
with you about that statement but yeah
you could have yeah yeah and we could
have made very easily 30k or something
at some point you know yeah a month
without restricting the user experience
for that you know we so I do remember
the slide that I presented at demo day
actually with sort of the long I think
it might have in the last slide which
was like the future vision which was
okay we're starting with tech that's
like a core longer term we want to
expand to gaming I'm actually from the
gaming world before all this and so I've
seen the challenges of game discovery
for consumers but also for people making
games and it's all steam done indie
games you know like a like a platform
agnostic steam kind of community
actually it's like that alone is a huge
business on its own yeah fashion and
like we even I love music
I love discovering music like that's
even an area so we were thinking
initially at one point like let's let's
that's really really amazing community
initially an endless expand and
replicate this model across multiple
verticals and that actually still to me
super exciting in like yeah I was sold
like I remember the slide I was like wow
I'm like I was convinced right yeah this
is definitely because you have this
initial kernel it's so hard for founders
that start where they can never get
traction on the first product then you
can't be creative and but you had you
had this like excitement and kernel and
capital and so like I was like super
excited I remember the demo day prior I
was like man I remember talking to you
in like the green room or something yeah
man I'm like super psyched like this is
like you know like I just remember being
really excited on for you and like being
like this is yeah why well there's I
don't forget what I did exactly said was
like - but yeah and everyone has like
you can imagine Venn diagrams everyone
is interested in multiple things like I
love music and I love games
I love tech that's like my Venn diagram
someone else might love fashion and
beauty and tech and so the idea was like
let's take all these circles and like
slowly expand like every kind of product
category and the learning though there's
a I was a little bit naive I think in
thinking that we could quickly replicate
and humidity's in these different
verticals and the the nature of even
just game discovery is quite different
than product and tech discovery and so
in hindsight we we tried to expand too
quickly in the beginning we didn't
properly build like a core solid like
gaming committee that was the first
vertical we moved into weird gaming then
we did books and then we did podcasts
yeah because podcasts also suffer from a
discovery like a problem and in wrexham
and YC application idea really oh yes I
have cast everything but definitely
podcast discoveries in that people send
it to me every batch what do you think
of this say there's like one dozen
companies
it's very common sorry a very tart very
hard and so yeah we we learned what what
happened is we ended up having almost
the entire communities still focused on
tech and their their frame of mind for
using product what was tech and tech
products and what resulted in in just
very little engagement in these other
kind of side communities and we were
unsuccessful in getting them spun up to
be like your own standalone like
community where people could you know
find the best game
or really visual it daily basis for that
type of call do you think you have a
template now of how you may have done
that in the past like the right people
to hire maybe even create a new like a
name it's not called product hunt
anymore yeah yeah we talked we
internally talked about a game hunt and
like expanding even buying hunting calm
and like expanding out that way and kind
of making a more general purpose and I
think this is one of the questions where
it's in hindsight I would love to see
how this play would play out but I don't
know if it would work yeah and one
scenario is we would build out separate
domain entirely and what that would
afford us to do is create an entirely
different experience designed for gaming
which would be more visual more videos
more imagery it might well it would
require people to have better ability to
focus in the the platform that they use
whether it's mobile or Xbox or
Playstation or whatnot
and that's a very different experience
than browsing I feel like you're so good
at community I can just picture you
could have used like really cool video
reviews or you would have had like the
equivalent of a maker like I I can like
see it right like I guess it's part of
my job but like just you describing I'm
like yeah that would be very different
than all the other video game describes
things and like that sounds really
useful yeah right there's nothing like
that right now and and still like
somebody should build it what we're now
focusing on is actually doubling so that
was one horizontal notes go really wide
build you know a network of properties
potentially instead what we focus on is
let's go deep because actually is as big
as this is this is also really big you
know focusing entirely just on
technology because who doesn't have an
iPhone first off or like an Android
phone you know there are some people in
the world but like more and more people
are adopting just a smartphone in their
pocket that alone every person that has
a smartphone in their pocket could be
user a prophet own doesn't mean that
we've designed an experience for
everyone today but the market
opportunity and and you know the
influence of technology is increasingly
growing so we've we sort of honed in and
I don't know three years ago probably
honed in on that that direction and said
let's go deeper into technology and
focus on that vertical and focus on our
bread-and-butter instead of trying to
spread so thin I mean so going deep
they're like sometimes people go up
market where they're like ok we'll also
do this thing for enterprises and you
could have helped people discover
enterprise software and man that sounds
super it look real ok so I can't help
but like brainstorm on the stuff so I'm
just through
you know back in the day when you have
everything lined up and round were the
things that you could have been excited
about that we're not selling out your
vision of what it could be but that
would have like allowed you to to go
super deep on this because again you
have resources now but it's a different
setup than if you were like trying to
build a company that you know could
employ a thousand people or become they
you know future of everything yeah so
one thing that was suggested earlier
Leon by a few of our investors because
they're their lenses as an investor and
investors were using product not defined
and stay updated school yeah and a few a
few different investors and people
suggested hey you should start a protect
fund yeah you should build a fund on top
of product and invest in use the data in
the community and everything to source
and find really early-stage
opportunities and I was pretty adamant
is tempting as it is to explore that
because I've always been interested in
investing pre product hunt I don't think
it was the right direction this is where
I personally just don't think that was
the right that would have been the right
outcome it would have actually changed
product n dramatically into a much
different type of business and kind of
be more like Angeles potentially then
again this I was saying is like there
was a way you could have from your
starting point could have actually been
angellist if you went down that path
yeah
and so again I'm not even saying it's
the right one there's also like
Kickstarter you could have been like oh
let's help people like you know imagine
that you could remember those
experiments people did were if enough
people took an action it would unlock
something launching do you remember that
there was like I charted that a hype
machine did like a bunch of sites like
10 years ago did this stuff yeah but you
would create collective action around
people's launches and either help them
actually sell products or monetize their
moments or get their initial user base
and I know you do begin to testers right
that's pretty cool are you ready yeah we
we've experimented with some things
again we sort of built a tool for people
to collect beta users like emails and
that kind of thing cuz like there's ways
that instead of taking equity in
companies you still could have provided
like pretty deep services deeper than
just click on our my website and maybe
sign up and like I think you bought have
happily paid for it like for sure so
yeah anyway it's yeah it doesn't matter
now but like I'm just like super
fascinated on thinking through just what
a great thing you had and all the ways
like like I've been in Silicon Valley a
long time
it's just like these little micro
decisions that is a difference between
you know Facebook being Facebook and
MySpace or like sites we haven't even
thought of like I don't know yeah
tagged remember that and like high-five
and like I remember all these people all
those companies yeah and like they were
there we were you know but little micro
decisions have really huge effects over
time yeah and I'm fascinated by that and
I think part of it this is a channel
going back to the money thing to when
you do raise a lot of money and you feel
like you have infinite runway you should
treat it like you don't and truthfully
there's some things that that I
prioritized on the team because I wanted
it myself like some redesign work that
we did which redesigns are oftentimes a
trap like there's times when you want to
do redesign work but often times it's
realistically not going to change your
numbers that all that much and
especially with something like what we
built where we have a community of
people like people really don't care if
the upload button looks a little bit
shinier like they're gonna use it or not
because of the content like the
conversation the people there and we're
all that dig redesigns
yeah yeah yeah yeah although dig dig I
don't blame them for the the for dunno I
think release was the one that really
had a problem I think that direction was
directionally like intuitive it was
movie it was we're in Twitter was taking
off and like how do you build some
that's even more accessible and builds
more retention loops through following
and that type of thing I think there's
some good ideas there but it's hard can
we use it really hard to because you
know don't like change don't they don't
and we've made changes that the
communities has been upset about and
some pieces we've reverted some cases we
let them get used to it but I think this
is a very real problem like a lot of
venture backed companies don't have that
same sense of urgency that you know like
indie Acker type companies have they're
like hey listen I could work on a
redesign for the next month or I could
like optimize my sales funnel and like
make you know a hundred thousand more
dollars so now that you guys are within
angel lists you could be a little more
slack maybe so like how are you creating
that urgency like what are you focusing
on right now yeah so we have so last
year and we have three KPIs actually
that we we measure revenues one of them
that was our number one priority last
year not because we are running out
because we just want to build a model
that can scale and cover expenses and so
where we hit profitability last year
second metric was just user growth how
do we get more people using product on
and the third is community contributions
and that's measured by the number of
people up voting commenting contributing
and that that's important cuz it's
basically the measurement of health if
we have nobody voting then we have
nothing so we want to make sure that's
that's good and this year we're
switching it around revenue is not the
number one priority we're switching
towards user growth and we're focusing
on kind of a couple different themes one
of them one of them I can't share too
many specifics on but it's a lot about
focusing on how do we help people find
the best products or the products they
should be using so product has always
been about the new products come here
open up the website you discover things
that you never would have searched for
because they didn't exist yesterday and
it's kind of a place to get like a
firehose of new cool stuff but a lot of
people in fact probably more people in
the world have a greater desire to find
the best products for specific things
and it could be something like I switch
from Android to iPhone you know what
apps should I be downloading and using
and exploring some of it might be I'm
starting new company what's the best
analytics tool for this budget for these
needs so really focusing on on this and
building out like a true product graph
is kind of what we're moving towards and
so that's one theme let's solve for that
use case and one by the way when we
build products we we have pretty good
process down where we'll have usually
one engineer to start with on it and
they drive the project forward alongside
like Julie or Dan on the design side and
so we're able to like do a lot of
projects at once which some people might
say is a bad thing but for us it works
really well the way we're set up and so
that's one thing we have going on then
we have going back to maker communities
we want to focus more on the social
networking kind of side of product on
and and technology and making itself and
we've kind of experiment and dabbled
with some of this but we're we're
starting to hone in on something that I
think is gonna work we'll see if it does
around virtual co-working and I don't
think I've used those words publicly at
all but there's this the people who are
most engaged on product and are working
on side projects they're freelancers
they're remote workers and they're just
really curious and eager and they have
desire to one meet other people like
them
get help from other people that are
maybe have a different skillset whether
it's design or engineering and and also
there's an aspect of loneliness too if
you're working on a project by yourself
like and especially if you're not in
Silicon Valley or like a tech hub like
where do you go and so we want to build
out ways for people to do all those
things on product and really support
this like future maker kind of ecosystem
going forward yeah I see you I see
applications along those lines of
basically remote work as a big trend
mm-hm and people are trying to think
about tools and like any mmmm there's a
bunch of ways to attack the problem but
for sure I'm very familiar with
excitement around making it easier
better faster for folks that are working
remotely all over the world to work
together and collaborate
he's got the tooling I mean we got slack
but tooling wise there's not a lot of
not much I mean there's not much Brian
and I both talked about this we're both
in long-distance relationships yeah and
he wasn't tweeting about it like what
are the solutions people are using yeah
it's super hacky tool whatsapp FaceTime
kind of stuff but that's it yeah yeah
yeah and there you should be like this
the other realization is I think some
people forget is most people also don't
have a large following online whether
it's Twitter or Facebook or whatever and
when you're building something and you
want feedback at best you ask your
friends and your friends gave you really
terrible positive advice because they
don't want to hurt your feelings and so
there's there's a greater need among
this giant audience of people to have
some sort of support network while
they're building and exploring yeah so I
was curious about this so there are a
bunch of questions basically people
asking for advice I'm like what makes a
successful product on product hunt and
like did you guys ever consider going in
that direction like more educational
content for your users yeah we have a
fake use and like how to's and things
like that but we've never never really
gone deep into the educational sites I
think this kind of goes back to her
saying like there's many different
things that we could build for product
ton and as much as I'd love to help
educate people it's not I think a core
focus Rose but yeah I think the general
advice really wouldn't come to like
people ask me all the time how what's
the best way to launch a product and
sometimes it's just simple advice like
make sure the imagery is really clear
the tagline is really clear
you know bounce it off a few people that
don't know you or don't know about your
product
and speak like a human not like a
marketer you know what I would love to
hear about is an example of your
favorite company that's ever launched on
product hunt that you're most proud of
almost like that you helped enable our
success and maybe the reverse but I
realize you can't but just like what's
an example of no one's specific but just
how someone can get to number one on
product hunt and have a good launch and
then actually like they didn't make
something people want and they turned
everybody and like you know what you've
learned and internalized about someone
with a great launch that in it sticks
and they really go off into the
stratosphere versus kind of like oh
people checked out my silly thing and
then there's nothing there like I love
you here yeah there's kind of couple
there's two different things that come
to mind one more recent actually and
this isn't a start-up actually it's not
a company but it's there's a number of
kind of self-described like indie makers
or people who are just eager to build
things not necessarily to make money
sometimes they do but sometimes it's
just to build things and show it show it
off and like be creative and explore and
we do this thing called golden kitty
Awards every every year which Canon
nominates different products in
different categories and we have one
category for like maker of the year and
we sort of take a look at all three up
votes and some data from the past year
to determine who that is and and I
apologize I might be forgetting his name
but as Andre if I'm not mistaken in
Europe he won maker of the year and this
is a younger guy who learned a code a
few years ago launched and his first
product a couple years ago on product
hunt after learning about 30 or 60 days
and then since then he's just he's
almost like he's got the bug he's got
the bug to build and I like to think
that at least part tent helped in some
way and giving him feedback because
otherwise when you build something you
spend all this time and no one uses it
no-one sees it it doesn't mean that they
have to like use it forever but like
getting some sort of feedback loops is
so important when you're building
something he he now has since built and
launched tons and tons of different
products and and I was happy to see like
he won maker of the year and he even
recorded the video put it on Twitter and
was like thanks everybody it's like so
happy so there's like the sort of
heartwarming like it's great to have a
tiny tiny piece of in supporting these
like future well these makers or maybe
future founders of companies but then
going to a company example one that
really sticks to mind is meerkat do you
member mirka so I've got to know Ben
actually saw him last weekend the CEO of
meerkat now house party and meerkat was
such an an awesome it it takes so many
boxes that were like perfect in terms of
the the messaging was really clear it
was I think the tagline was something
along the lines of broadcast live video
to your Twitter followers it was very
specific actually and the product design
was built for leveraging in a Twitter
graph which I think today still is
underutilized actually and quickly a
roaster prominent like blew up everyone
was using it for a little while and the
problem was that the product itself was
not retentive and you know most people
are really bad including myself at live
video it's just really hard to create
good content and to watch live ID you
have to watch it when it's live - so
there's like all these challenges with
the product when it comes to retention
and being something that works but what
they did realize kind of within that is
some people were sort of hacking it and
using meerkat to hang out with friends
and that's what ultimately like inspired
house party which is an app you open it
up and you and your friends immediately
are in like a video chat and you can
just hang out in chat and it's solving
this like underlying desire of
connection and and being together with
like people remote and and your friends
maybe back home or your girlfriend or
whoever hmm and is that was just like an
interesting example because it blew up
immediately and and yet at the same time
it required Ben and the team to be
thoughtful and like honest with
themselves like they could have run they
could have run out of money and run the
company into the ground if they were
persistent and thinking that this would
work that meerkat would work as it is
today yeah instead they had to change
that's really smart like yeah and that's
a great example we were talking earlier
like knowing where that decision point
is and it they didn't it wasn't like a
hard pivot where they did something
radically different but clearly yeah you
know I'm really curious to know Dalton
you've probably read like what 10,000
applications a lot about an infinite
about all of the applications yeah you
know I'm just kind of connecting the
dots now but like both of you guys
basically like review products all year
round and I'm curious like how much time
do you actually spend on product hunt in
like
in your YC application reading mine like
are you filtering through it in the same
way or are you just curious about oh
this is a cool side project I'll try it
out I think the most important thing
that I look at is how serious the
founders are and if they really made
something and showed it to people and so
it's almost like it doesn't matter if
the product is good so many people that
apply aspirationally maybe you want to
build something someday possibly yeah
but for the people that are serious
enough to really make something and be
brave enough to show it to other people
and be willing to take all of those like
you know it's really scary to do that
you know and so when you see someone
that's actually made something and
they're willing to share it with the
world and they they show that commitment
but they're serious about it I am paying
attention to you and I care less about
like the scale of the revenue like I was
saying earlier I care less about if the
design is really good like those things
are nice but man if the difference
between someone that's serious and not
serious is all the difference in the
world does that make so how do you
evaluate that in applications how do you
know this you can see if they've done
something like again like do you even do
you have a prototype do you have a first
user mm have you made a dollar of
revenue like again it's very it depends
on the type of company it is but you can
see the difference between hey I want to
raise money before I work on this yeah
that's a certain sort of thing and
that's not really are necessarily our
bread-and-butter and then the people
that you can tell that they're gonna
work on their dream no matter what with
or without you and that you can
hopefully help them in some way and
again I would put you with you you did
it like no one like no one told you hey
you should go make product huh you
should make this email list like you
weren't trying I don't think trying to
please investors you were just trying to
do something you thought was cool yeah
and that was the kernel of goodness that
you had right like you figure that on
your own without authority figures
telling you to do it and like that's
really special and that's a huge signal
yeah one one thing I've been thinking a
lot about is I was fortunate in that I
been working in a previous company for
three years after three years I was like
I gotta I gotta do something different I
gave notice that turned into part-time
Rolle actually so cut my salary in half
or 20 hours a week that gave me plenty
of time for product n so I was lucky and
that I could financially support myself
as I was tinkering and building and a
lot of people just don't especially in
San Francisco and I've been thinking
more about this challenge and maybe it's
that be curious if YC is thinking about
this but like how do you how do you give
people that opportunity to quit their
job and give them six months or 12
months whatever the time is to do that
because you know you can do a lot of
nights and weekends and I think people
underestimate that but there's also some
people just have challenges and like
having a no and to truly see something
through without quitting their job yeah
so in start-up school which is the
online course thing that we have anyone
could participate you definitely don't
need to be full-time there's even for a
small percentage of people that are
really serious we give them grants mmm I
think this is all in our blog yeah I'm
like there's how much do you give ten
thousand ten grand yeah to everyone are
just justices certainly did a hundred
companies yeah oh wow so you know again
we can't can't be for everyone but those
are people were they were really serious
they were really working hard and we you
know that could be really helpful to
them and again the whole point of start
of school was like even for people that
haven't quit their job it gives you a
chance to be serious and structured in
your thinking right put on your calendar
and make progress there's so many people
that want to start a start-up and
whether or not they quit their jobs they
never like begin yeah like a lot of
people men like would never even think
about
I should go part-time I should go twenty
hours a week like a lot of people never
get the confidence and never feel like
they're good enough and to do the thing
so I startup school is awesome there
yeah but for you like what motivated you
to be like yeah you know what I can do
part-time I can make this work it was it
was more that I I just knew I just knew
deep in my heart that I need to do
something different because I I was I
felt like I wasn't learning and I love
love the company love the team and but
it you know there's certain moments I
think in everyone's career people who
have worked with me you know that I've
transitioned out you know it's been a
good transition because I saw like I get
it like I know why you're leaving and I
know why it's maybe not a good place for
anymore so for me I just I forced myself
and I I knew it was just gonna leave
entirely and not do part-time and
like I have a little bit of money saved
I'll figure it out and maybe I was a
little bit I don't know naive in that
sense but it did work out and you know
there's a reason why I actually named
the fund I started weekend fun though -
because I I think a lot of amazing
companies and amazing things can be
built on a weekend if you can afford the
time and I think a lot of people tend to
now I don't want to some people a family
some people have financial burns like
things like that that certainly are
debilitating but I think for a lot of
people there are no excuses not to be
working on the weekend and like trying
and making some progress yeah well if
you want to do is start it but not
everyone like it's not for everybody
but like - if you're if you're curious
you have to start and man does that
screen out a lot of people if they don't
like start yeah yeah yeah in the
progress - there's something about as I
speak with companies and look at now
from an investor side a little bit
progress is like everything and just
even if it's it doesn't have to be you
know 50 percent month-over-month growth
but I've invested in companies after
following them for even just two or
three weeks of giving me more confidence
based on what they're shipping and how
they're interacting with their users and
those types of small micro like
day-to-day interactions really matter a
lot yeah I mean I think that's a great
place to wrap it up but uh yeah
thanks for coming in guys yeah thanks a
me Coakley [ __ ]
you